farmers in quu Province know fix chisaki
wants a second term as president of the
Democratic Republic of Congo but
opinions here are divided on whether he
deserves they vote some are disappointed
and frustrated by Rising poverty
unemployment and the slow pace of
development the head of state has
responsibilities towards the people in
other words he is indebted to us he
didn't really fulfill his promises
chisti is hoping his Pro for social
policies to improve education and
healthare will get him
reelected and some congales feel the
same way I think that the president's
first term was merely a preparatory one
let's give him a chance for a second ter
so that he can finalize his projects the
general election is on December the 20th
chisaki could face stiff competition
from opposition candidates who are also
promising to alleviate poverty as well
as deal with corruption in government
and
in the Eastern DRC harumasa
aler make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz